tu sais que mon môme ma copine la c1
lémuriens assaillir genre et cas
lémuriens et on mes amis c'est le père
noël
du des trucs de noël et d'ailleurs mon
meilleur ami t'embrasse et tu sais que
maman a le coeur brisé parce que parce
que papa il a embrassé une elfe
non je suis dans une soucoupe volante en
fait là
non j'ai pas pris de drogue ce presque
m'accroche à l'air simple et moi et je
suis un moineau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
j'ai mis comment est-ce qu'on reconnaît
un aveugle sur une plage nudiste
je sais pas c'est pas dur
je sais pas ce n'est pas laid c'est pas
dur mais je ne sais pas pas compris la
flotte la plus belle rencontre que j'ai
fait ici je passe c'est la plus belle
rencontre mais
j'ai rencontré
j'ai rencontré brad pitt enfin plutôt il
a rencontré mon dos parce que quand je
suis arrivé ici j'avais 17 ans j'avais
juste jouer dans un court métrage et un
jour je suis arrivée devant un mur là du
palais du palais des festivals du
festival et il y avait une un mur de
photographes
derrière une vitre et j'étais persuadé
que c'était pour nous pour notre court
métrage me dis moi en fait cannes c'est
un vrai délire quoi tu arrives même si
tu es un petit court métrage en fait
t'es gentil
et là une main ma décalé pour passer et
c'était juste brad pitt avec angelina
jolie à l'époque et il m'a dit ça et il
m'a poussé gentiment voilà c'était ma
rencontre avec brad pitt et ma rencontre
avec avec l'humilité en une seconde